abordabilité coût de la vie inflation
depuis le début de la campagne les chefs
cogné sur le même clou et les électeurs
en font aussi une priorité
c'est une préoccupation pour beaucoup
d'électeurs et les partis politiques
l'ont compris chaque jour on entend des
annonces et des promesses pour aider les
ontariens à faire face au coût de la vie
qui explose mais ce que cette réalité
aura vraiment un impact le jo du 2 juin
on est allé voir trois électeurs avec
des réalités très différentes pour
sonder leurs impressions à quelques
semaines du scrutin
harry numéro un à aurora en bons du nord
de toronto la genèse 47 ans a deux
enfants sa conjointe et lui ont des
emplois bien rémunérés
mais même pour eux les factures
commencent à peser a rejeté un orange
hier c'était une pièce et 69 points
oranges
résultat il faut couper dans le budget
familial et reporter certaines dépenses
la rénovation de la cuisine devra donc
attendre quelques mois
en plus des effets immédiats sur son
portefeuille daniel s'inquiète pour
l'avenir de sa famille surtout avec
l'augmentation des taux d'intérêt à
sonatrach très peu être repoussé à on
pense même plus à la retraite pour
l'année
satisfaits du gouvernement fouad mais ne
révèle pas pour qui il votera pas contre
en partie cette fois-ci mesure votée
avec un parti arrêt numéro deux dans le
centre-ville de toronto sarr abdillahi
25 ans ne sais pas encore pour qui elle
votera mais l'inflation influencera
certainement sa décision
tout coûte beaucoup plus cher remarque
l'étudiante pour faire face au coût de
la vie qui augmente sa race y trouver un
emploi
à plus long terme elle s'inquiète de ne
pas avoir les moyens de vivre à toronto
je serai prêt
étudiant promet de voter mais se désole
que les politiciens n'offre pas de
mesures spécifiques pour aider les
jeunes à faire face à l'inflation elle
se serait écrasé dans
un arrêt numéro trois habitants en
banlieue éloignée de toronto prenez des
sarts 60 et en donnera son appui à
d'oxford le 2 juin prochain mais ce
n'est pas de gaieté de coeur qu'il
faudra pour les conservateurs les
conservateurs les dépense trop il
devance trop le policier à la retraite a
déjà dû faire des choix difficiles à
cause de l'inflation je l'aimais trop
chaleureux comme celui d'arrêter
d'utiliser sa camionnette qui roulent au
diesel une situation irritante pour lui
comme pour beaucoup de ses voisins en
milieu rural le manque de mort s'ils ont
besoin des voitures de pointe rapport
public et ce n'est pas que derrière le
volant que rené doit modifier ses
habitudes
normalement au monde le plus de viande
chaque semaine mais on en mange moins en
dépit de ces ajustements rené se
considère chanceux le retraité croit
avoir assez d'epargne pour faire face à
l'inflation
j'étais gala de toute ma vie pas mal
mais pour les jeunes moi je trouve que
c'est c'est dur c'est elle a commencé
pour faire face à l'inflation les
conservateurs promettent encontre de
réduire la taxe sur l'essence les
libéraux de fixer le prix du transport
en commun à 1 $ et le npd d'améliorer
l'accès au logement abordable autant de
promesses qui pourrait faire pencher les
indécis le 2 juin prochain et s'il ya
une média radio canada toronto
[Musique]